tell me what to be more depressed cuz
I'm gonna get more depressed but tell me
what it is now um I was scrolling
through Twitter today and I stumbled
upon a link that Opie and Jimmy put out
and it was fifty hottest men in comedy
and you didn't make the cut baby you
were a turtleneck and everything hold on
can I just say something though right
now bogus
give me the list right now wait no they
didn't do it BuzzFeed did it oh wait
wait the BuzzFeed did the 15 BuzzFeed
did it but Opie and Jimmy because they
followed them on Twitter they who is Jim
Norton nonetheless no I'm fine if George
Norton made the list cuz he is just like
me but he's the white version I'm fine I
don't want to hate on anybody but
anybody that I find sexy and comedy did
not make the list mark and Mary made fit
let me tell you another thing
Marc Maron is [ __ ] hot he is so
scrumptious and he is number 50 you
think that Marc Maron is hot
yes he's fresh bread or so he is not
scrum to it oh my god he is so
attractive to me
sorry I can't even look at him you wanna
guess the top five it's disgusting
cookies ready okay alright you're just
[ __ ] it up for me I'll talk about it
Jeselnik he's in there but not top five
Chris D'Elia he's in there but not top
five de la santé not top five what's his
name from community what's his name Joel
McHale Joel McHale he's in there but not
top five someone else will come here
dear Ken Jong let me ask you this
they're not ken Jeong in The Times no
Asian fine this guy's a racist he's good
the only one they had is like Aziz
Ansari
that's Indian that is asian asian yeah
of course he's gonna be in it number one
John Mulaney you
you know what like if you think he's I
mean like the face face is okay number
two Nick is very happy to let me just
picture by the way yeah soon the best
he's he's really number two dudes the
best number three guess what
shorts thing as a stand-up donald glover
the black guy yeah yeah yeah he's cute
number four Nerdist Chris Hardwick stop
stop it for it's not before I'm stop
stop it for what's your problem with him
well I love them I you know I've known
him for many years I've done Chelsea
with them I've done his show at midnight
he's a very funny guy is that a great
brain but I wouldn't [ __ ] him and I'm
not even a like Nick Thune he looks like
a model Oh Nick Thune and I of clothes I
mean I'll hang out with him but wouldn't
we see each other there's excitement we
hug this and that we [ __ ] around with
each other in in in if you weren't if
him and I were in the war like in Syria
were fighting Syrian and whoever
fighting al-qaeda or and would and I
would probably suck his dick
father nothing's wrong right hell will
you do it like you know we're gonna die
Oh bus speeds against fat boys I think
Bert Kreischer is not on there Seguros
either Tom Segura is not in there
there's super daddy sexy I'm sure is
five who Natasha Leggero
oh yeah he's five he's number five oh
you're right about Joel McHale he's
right after him six no just handsome
baby yeah it's that Steve Burns on it no
all right Oh handsome very handsome very
handsome Steve Byrne
yeah I have a note at BuzzFeed right now
you're being very Trump ish mmm you're
wrong true Steve Burns should be on that
list and um the thought that he's not in
it just makes me angry is I'm adamant on
that list now whoa well Rogen's not even
on that list
Nick Kroll beat
Josh wolf yeah that's absurd it's absurd
right Josh was very Josh wolf is a
definitely [ __ ] guy yeah that's a
[ __ ] up list you know what guys
welcome we hope that not BuzzFeed
boycott yeah you know what yeah that's
it you know for a week for seven days
now we're doing a BuzzFeed boycott
they're not gonna listen to us sweetie
it doesn't matter we're so small they're
giant it doesn't matter and they have a
corgi is there no you know what because
you said that because you said that I
would across them starting our own
website list no we're gonna start our
own list [ __ ] BuzzFeed yeah they're
pretty shitty lately it's not that it's
just that the things that they like it's
like I'm you know it's not nothing that
I like what they like I don't like you
know they talk about things I don't like
you know about like the best you know
players go it's just clickbait you
shouldn't take it personally if they put
you on there it wouldn't be clicked wait
yeah you know what BuzzFeed I guess
you're only you're only at 15 Wow it's
incredible let me out of all of them in
terms of I'm just gonna say this out
loud because I've been in comedy for a
very long time and I know a lot of
[ __ ] people in terms of ratio [ __ ]
ratio top five D'Elia
100% I don't know how Marc Maron's v
John Mulaney
John Mulaney I'm gonna bet in my luck in
he's probably too had sex with ten girls
it's not that he can do it do more but
you know he's you know a shy very nice
guy know that al Qaeda this is what I do
know what I do know that he's not at the
Lea numbers you don't know maybe he's a
quiet killer you know
no baby he's not Galia numbers has you
have no idea babe he's the king of it
well I I believe it and now you know who
the second King is that he won't he's
only even the top thousand Daniel Tosh
Pauly Shore oh that's true yeah he's I
mean you want to do in terms of ratio
Pauly Shore chillin in the game since
1987 MTV brah okay you're not on this
George
[Music]